so like favors men really so it's how
it's a bit unfair to just say how does
Okay can I can I have an example how how
does society favor men well like the
high paying jobs I know you're gonna say
women don't want to do the the high
paying jobs but most of the high paying
jobs they favor men like a woman has to
work
let me ask you she wants those roles let
me let me ask you a question NBA it's
mostly 60 70 black roughly do they
discriminate against Asians there's like
no Asians in the NBA oh so you're saying
they're better no no no no no no no I'm
saying does the NBA discriminate against
Asians there are very few Asians in the
NBA what I'm saying is in any group you
you're never gonna find true equality
when it of outcome because different
groups like different things